جواد ذكريات
في اشخاص
رحلوا عنا وفي اشخاص
اصيبوا ولكن الكلمه بقيت اقوى
والعربيه استمرت اول شيء يعني اسمح لي انه
اخرج عن النص
مكتوب وهيك اقف وانحني عفوا امام بطولاتك
وامام مهنيتك عفوا نحن نفخر فيه او هتطلل
شفناك فيها شيخ الشباب كنت بهالفيديو
فانت بدك تخبرنا
الصحافه
واهميه الكلمه مهما كان الثمن اولا اشكرك
جدا وانت زميلتنا واختنا واستاذتنا
وعزيزتنا واشكر كل الزملاء هو اليوم احنا
نحتفل يعني هو يوم مفرح اكيد
بوجودك
كل الزملاء وتعرفين مسيره العشرين عام
مسيره طويله عمر يعني اللي انولد مع تاسيس
العربيه الان شاب وعنده شوارب ولحيه وربما
متزوجه ابني ما يعرفني يعني تغيرت
واشتعل الرئيس وشيء بلان نقدر نقول يعني
طبعا مسيره طويله
عشرين عام مرت بيها احداث كثيره
عطاء كبير من عدد هائل من الزملاء سواء
اللي يظهرون على الشاشه او اللي خلف
الشاشه
ما من شك انه العربيه هي براند مهم في
عالم الاعلام العربي ومن يعمل في العربيه
نقطه مهمه في السي في انه هو عمل في مؤسسه
رصينه مؤسسه محترفه
مؤسسه مواكبه للاحداث
تتعامل بمهنيه وبعلميه عاليه ومتطوره
ومتجدده متجدده تعرفين قبل 20 سنه الاعلام
ليس كما هو اليوم يعني كان حتى الموبايلات
هذي كنا اذا نريد ننقل لقطه عشر ثواني
لازم ننصب سياره وديش والمهندس يضبط مع
القمر الصناعي الان على الواتساب يوصل
للمحرر وتطلع الخبر بثواني مش من صحفي لا
من مواطن عادي وهذه كانت اهميه العربيه ان
بكل الظروف وبكل الاوقات استطاعت ان تطور
وان تخلق الافكار الجديده حتى تستمر
وتتكامل مع كل الاجيال التي تتابعها الزمن
يمشي وكانه اسرع من الطبيعه واللي ما
يواكب الزمن يبقى بالخلف والناس اللي
بالمقدمه والمؤسسات الجمل للناجحين وليس
للمتنكئين او المتخلفين واعتقد العربيه من
من رواد المتقدمين في عالم الاعلام يعني
احنا نعمل بالعربيه بس هذا واقع يعني
اردنا في هذه الفقره ان نتحدث عن تغطيه
العراق يعني انت تعلم العراق له حيثيته
اكيد
والاحداث اللي مرت عليه كبيره جدا
وانطلقت قناه العربيه مع
الهزمه هزت العالم والشرق الاوسط بدخول
القوات الى بغداد دعنا نتكلم عن التغطيات
وخصوصيتها على ارض العراق
يعني انا اكثر من مره قلتها انه في زمن
يعني في التغطيات العسكريه الحربيه
قد لا يكتفي الصحفي بمهنيته انه كونه صحفي
يجيد الكتابه والتعليق واداره عمليه
التصوير حتى ينجح في ظروف مثل ظروف العراق
يجب ان يتمتع بحس امني عالي حتى يحمي نفسه
ويحمي زملائه من ظروف العمل المحيطه
المعروفه يعني تعرفين انه دخلت الى بغداد
فقط القوات الامريكيه هو تحالف واسع فقط
القوات الامريكيه حدود 130 الف جندي
فتصوري حجم العمليات العسكريه كم هو واسع
وانهيار بلد في ايام معدوده
يعني حصل ارباك كبير